boa tarde pessoal que agradeceu o ted o
marcel principalmente a e punível o
convite e falar um pouco sobre o que
ocorria sob cerâmica estou no ramo há 30
anos e tenho talvez um pouquinho para
transmitir a vocês sorriram 11 e sub
aproveitamento de resíduos sólidos é uma
das perguntas uma vez que a cerâmica
pode ter uma grande parceira nesse
sentido o proprietário da série fardinha
é eu sou profissional sou engenheiro
agrônomo
mas é meu bebê e optei por mexer não com
o solo na com subsolo que é assim né
então eu trabalho nisso aí já há um
tempo e desenvolver os trabalhos
inclusive atualmente desenvolvido até o
1 o próprio if há atualmente é o setor
cerâmico
ele é existir no país em torno de 6.000
cerâmicas falar um pouquinho a
panorâmica da cerâmica no brasil no
estado do rio mas tenho mais ou menos
180 do qual 120 está localizada no norte
do estado que a campos e gera em torno
de 300.000 emprego vendeu algo em torno
de 18 bilhões de faturamento a mal então
só de nós temos nos últimos anos nem e
principalmente da lei 12.015 placar
devido à retração da construção civil a
cerâmica não ficou atrás disso
mas se alguém mora na baixada aqui por
exemplo a nossa economia anterior à
cultura da cana das cerâmicas a a
cerâmica ela cultura da cana de açúcar e
as usinas foram fechando e isso aí foi
dando lugar a outros e duas também quer
ver as coisas têm que continuar
desenvolvendo e hoje toda aquela mão de
obra ali só quer absolvido pelo setor do
sul logo do setor sucroalcooleiro hoje
absolvido pela cerâmica então é difícil
alguém que mora na baixada não teve uma
pessoa direta ou indiretamente ligada ao
setor
me deu então é nós estamos é hoje o
itajaí e vi por baleias extintor de
6.000 cerâmicas mas só nesses últimos
anos fecharam no brasil em torno de
2.000 2.000 cerâmicas porque isso porque
senão questão é é se industrializando
acho que não estão não estando é não tem
grandes aproveitamento diante rendimento
onu estão se profissionalizando elas
estão saindo fora do mercado é como
todas as empresas têm que ser assim
hoje nós desenvolvemos é eu vou dizer o
seguinte que a nossa matéria prima
chamada argila que moscou reconhece como
barro ela ela quando me descida ela se
torna plástica então ela pode
desenvolver em vários formatos e tem um
gosto de ferro maior presença menor
presença ea da colorações diferentes de
matéria-prima podemos podemos ter vários
formatos e várias cores
então quando você consegue determinar
isso e você pode fazer obras primas
maravilhosas e deu só que grande parte
das cerâmicas fato o meu produto
e depois querem é ter resultados
diferentes e eu não temo tem um problema
sério com os produtos substitutos né
sabia que até os anos até na década de
20 75% do pib mundial vai ser formado
por produtos que nem foi inventado ainda
a inovação tecnológica é muito rápida e
hoje muitos empresários pararam no tempo
e não tão menos que vasco e estou
mudando mas vou falar quais o
micro-ônibus e as coisas também no setor
cerâmico está evoluindo muito rápido
então eu procuro sempre a andar um pouco
na frente mas para poder acompanhar
nessa inovação ea cerâmica ela ela faz
parte de saber desse contexto defendeu
eu dizia eu tenho trabalhado na pasta
que a página área ambiental na uf estava
em um curso de engenharia ambiental e o
setor cerâmico é muito importante
principalmente você pode e é pegar
determinados resíduos sólidos desde que
não tem elementos químicos pesados e
misturar na massa cerâmica
então vocês dewani conta que o consumo
diário de argila no brasil está em torno
me engano 19 milhões de toneladas dia
se vocês colocarem um a dois por cento
de resíduos nessa massa para produzir
produtos grande uma parte de dos
resíduos gerados por essas indústrias
teria lá um destino ambiental eu tenho
vários trabalhos feito que é a parte que
interessa e resíduo principalmente a
parte de pádua e granito de padrão
porque quando você corta você corta 11
granito você gera resíduo
esses resíduos eles são é r ricos
principalmente prudentes que a nossa
matéria prima ela é deficiente
então eu uso o exemplo o review de sorte
de resíduos de tanto da parte de pago
quanto à parte de cachoeiro itapemirim
que gera milhões e milhões de toneladas
de resíduos por dia e se registou
colocado em aterro sanitário e
tratamento de é vários problemas
ambientais
eu ea minha empresa e nós desenvolvemos
aqui no pneu temos de ver totalmente
trabalho nesse sentido o resíduo hoje lá
em cachoeiro a gente põe pádua misto da
minha massa além de diminuir reduzir o
consumo dessa matéria prima se chama da
china que é infinita é possível
prolongar a durabilidade da minha
reserva e às vezes consigo a agregar
valor ao produto melhorando muitas vezes
a qualidade do produto
a agenda de campos por exemplo ela é
pobre em potássio e sódio são dois
fundantes que age a ajuda a fundir as
partículas de argila para dar o material
de maior qualidade
quando trata os resíduos de de granito
eu consiga somar é favorecida e e além
de resolver o problema que a minha tia
tem deficiência e melhorar a qualidade
do produto é esse trabalho que tem
desenvolvido onde qual efe
e por último desenvolvendo também com if
lá do centro relação a representar muito
calor já que o trabalho também com
relação à celulose de da copa de pádua
ela produz é papel higiênico nem produz
resíduos e esses resíduos
eles estão e são colocados em aterro
sanitário também desenvolver se
desenvolver o trabalho com efe
hoje esses êxitos são usados sempre de
alguma cena de campos e nós ainda somos
pago para poder utilizar esse êxito
eles colocam na nossa empresa é deus em
tempos de frete ainda nos paga 10 reais
por tonelada
pra casa pra usar esse e isso favorece
ainda na extrusão da minha massa porque
eu gosto mesmo na pele para poder
produzir esse jogo eu gasto menos
combustível porque o a celulose ela em
dentro da massa cerâmica
depois de tempo de 400 grau ela como ela
ela pega fogo entendeu então ela
confiava que consome e gerando energia e
gastando menos combustível pra poder
dizer esta semana que o trabalho no
congresso desenvolvido na são paulo né é
aquela é uma professora do natal ela é
professor do if lá de cima cair ela
estava comigo nesse congresso e não
estava lá para defender um trabalho
diretamente cerâmica
então eu sempre faço trabalho de
pesquisa
aqui eu vi 7
muitos de vocês conhecem né não vamos
trabalhar e estão fazendo um trabalho
junto agora lá em na minha cerâmica eu
é coisa no if também é o trabalho
desenvolvido um f
com relação aos resíduos e inclusive
esse aquele ali intertravado cerâmico
ele e é exatamente os sons palavras
existe muito de cimento né isso aqui eu
eu desenvolvi aqui no estado do rio se
envolvesse que chama da colômbia de
attock ele tem uma resistência e 45 na
época pascal alta resistência e o
interessante desse produto que daqui a
30 anos ele vai ter a mesma cor porque a
argila que é vermelha no um concorrente
de cimento e de johnson e geralmente são
corantes são pigmentos que os 23 anos
espera daquela cor e depois fica tudo e
com forlán e escura
o trabalho foi desenvolvendo a minha
semana que a união no estado rita
desenvolver esse trabalho por enquanto é
o chamado nem a dock é muito usado na
europa na qual na até na colômbia
a geração de novos produtos cerâmicos
não é porque um padre que vocês que as
empresas elas têm que inovar
constantemente se nós vamos brevemente
vou sair fora do mercado até então está
aí nós temos que estar sempre buscando
novos parceiros e agentes principal
estão aí aonde as universidades
vocês são é o iff ea uff é um grande
parceiro nesse sentido que poderão
ajudar as empresas a desenvolver novos
produtos em cima de segurança estão
trabalhando aqui foi um trabalho que
desenvolvi com efe
nós temos financiamento para isso porque
te deixa pachi que elas nos patrocina
ela quer dizer que queremos desenvolver
uma pesquisa na nossa empresa que faz o
projeto for aprovado existe
financiamento até dinheiro e fui
perdendo esse trabalho foi desenvolvido
com a faperj que desenvolve há oito anos
lá da qual o chefe apache
ótimo trabalho que deu um ótimo
resultado inclusive tem até empresas e
outras empresas usando em campos
principalmente na fabricação de telhas
no caso da seringa foi josé diminui a
absorção e eo aumento da resistência
desses produtos
esse aí são exigentes e industriais que
nós usamos né
há outras empresas são poluentes para
nós e venha ser a solução
com relação à redução de de matéria
prima é o trabalho que eu desenvolvi lá
na vôo
o trabalho que eu fiz lá num certo
sucesso das cerâmicas e falar em são
paulo e no congresso que eu fui que eu
defendi sublevação tecnológica da ufcg
serra do trabalho foi desenvolvido lá
vocês seguinte sabe que a deixar bem
pesado aqui que a indústria cerâmica ela
foi detida ela pode ser uma grande
parceira com relação à utilização de
resíduos
entendeu-se que é exigível é todo todos
produzidos em grande parte desse êxito
sou uma pequena parte né
já disse que não tem elementos químicos
pesados elas podem ser estudado
misturado na massa cerâmica e produzir
novos produtos e reduzir custo e
melhorar a qualidade desses produtos do
nosso produto cerâmico já que a nossa
região ela ela trabalha como já estamos
há 30 ou 40 anos desenvolvendo uma
referência na região e eu acho que ea
pesquisa tem que continuar esse trabalho
tem que continuar sendo feito para
trazer obras mais duráveis é um produto
possível de vida é maior né
tem que parar de produzir ué
cerâmicas e outros produtos com cinco
muito curto que se gera uma uma enorme
quantidade de matéria prima que quase
nem sempre são renováveis
então a arte cerâmica farinha ela tem
trabalhado nesse sentido
já a aos 10 anos desenvolvendo novos
produtos
bom gente é isso aí que vocês passarem a
mensagem para vocês na página e
ambiental a cerâmica pode ser uma grande
parceira com relação à utilização desses
resíduos
obrigado
[Aplausos]